oui parce que moi j'aime beaucoup la
lecture
j'en ai des livres pour enfants qui ont
été choisis par mes enfants j'en ai
aussi des romans d'aventurés que je
lisais quand j'étais un adolescent puis
j'en ai des ligues plus sérieux aussi
des livres d'histoire pour pour
m'éduquer donc moi j'aime beaucoup lire
je pense que c'est très important et
nous passons maintenant à la question de
juliet y en a une question pour vous
quand vous veniez à l'école primaire de
saint ange est ce que vous pensez déjà
devenir astronaute
c'est inscrit
oui quand j'étais à l'école privée saint
ange moi je rêvais de l'espace mais je
pensais pas que c'était possible d'être
astronaute
mais je rêvais d'être un explorateur
c'est un peu la même chose
merci et nous passons maintenant à la
question d'élise
bonjour j'ai une question à vous poser
est ce que vous faites et niel dans
l'espace est-ce que vous pouvez voir le
père noël de la station spatiale
internationale
oui on va fêter noël ici on a des gens
de tous les pays et dans tous les pays
en fait noël alors on va fêter noël
ensemble en pensant à nos familles on a
amené chacun de la nourriture spéciale
de notre pays pour faire goûter à nos
amis et le père noël je passe le reste
ira le voir on voit là on voit le pôle
nord du simi est comme un peu au bord de
l'horizon je vais on va essayer de le
regarder on a des bonnes jumelles
on va voir s'il peut réussir à le voir
et on passe maintenant à la question de
matteo bonjour davet de saint jean j'ai
une question pour vous quel travail
faites vous dans la station spatiale
internationale
alors ici la station spatiale
c'est un laboratoire on fait de la
recherche scientifique
ça veut dire qu'on étudie le corps
humain et on étudie les maths la matière
on étudie les étoiles
on étudie la terre c'est un peu comme
comme une université la station spatiale
internationale
soit c'est une grosse partie de travail
aussi mais des fois il faut le réparer
quand les choses sont cassés il ya plein
de machines ici alors on peut beaucoup
de passe beaucoup de temps à réparer et
puis aussi à nettoyer parce que c'est
notre maison on vit ici
alors c'est une partie d'un travail
aussi c'est de s'occuper de notre
station de la garder en bon état comme
toi tu t'occupes de ta chambre
merci merci on passe maintenant à la
question de l'origine le construisent
15h02 le bras robotique canadien bonjour
david saint jacques
j'ai une question à vous poser est ce
que vous pouvez voir les zones les plus
polluées de la planète terre
alors la pollution des fois on la voit
un petit peu parce que quand on vole au
dessus des grandes grandes villes on
peut voir qu'il ya comme un nuage gris
là au dessus des grandes villes le sont
peut voir ça c'est la chose est plus
facile à voir qui nous montre la
pollution c'est la pollution de l'air
merci mais aussi des fois on voit
l'effet du réchauffement climatique
parce qu'on peut voir que les glaciers
dans les montagnes sont plus petits
maintenant qu'ils étaient il ya cent ans
et nous allons être en avait qu'une la
prochaine question de liliane quelle
était votre activité préférée à l'école
primaire et lorqu'elle bathiard étiez
vous le meilleur à mon activité préférée
moi j'aime ça les cours d'arts
plastiques j'aimais beaucoup ça le
bricolage
j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé ça et puis
ma matière préférée quand j'étais à
l'école primaire
j'aimais beaucoup ça le français moi
j'aimais beaucoup ça lire écrire c'était
ça ma matière préférée quand j'étais à
l'école primaire
aussi j'aime beaucoup les cours d'arts
plastiques
et maintenant nous allons avec une
question de juliet comment faites vous
pour garder vos hôtes vous muscler par
les salines dans l'espace
très important parce que si on fait rien
dans l'espace car c'est un an après
quand un espace là tu vois on flotte
comme ça quand dans une piscine tout eu
si on fait rien on va perdre tous nos
muscles et tous nés au zoo
puis quand leur revenir sur terre je
pourrais pas marché parce que je vais
pas je vais être capable de prendre des
enfants sur les épaules quand je veux
revenir alors on a une machine
d'exercice sont fait des exercices tous
les jours ont fait deux heures
d'exercice par jour
on court on a du vent 20 vélos
stationnaires on à tapis roulant avec un
harnais qui nous tient pour pâques on
s'envole puis on peut courir dessus
qu'on a une machine pour faire comme des
poids et haltères et avec ça on peut
rester en très bonne forme
merci la prochaine question vient
d'élise
quel est votre routine dans l'espace
alors on vit des journées à peu près
normal on est à la même on n'est pas à
l'heure du canada par exemple on vit à
l'heure de l'angleterre
et c'est comme si six heures plus tard
ici votes reçus chez moi y ait quatre
heures d'après midi et on se réveille le
matin vers 6 heures on se brosse les
dents on se lave un peu on va la
toilette on déjeune là on parle à notre
chef qui était houston et on planifie la
journée et puis là toute la journée on
travaille on s'arrête pour manger le
midi on fait des exercices on compte
travailler l'après midi le soir on parle
encore un chef pour pouvoir parler de la
journée et après ça on peut super et là
on a le temps petit peu le soir pour
rappeler notre famille ou peut-être
écrire une lettre ou faire des photos de
la terre à partir de la fenêtre
c'est ça notre routine et la dernière
question reviendra de matteo
comment faites vous pour vous l'avez
dans l'espace
très bonne question alors on peut pas
prendre de douche parce que imagine si
je prenais une douche l'eau avait pas
vouloir tomber dans le fond de la 200 à
bois flotté alors ce qu'on fait c'est
que imaginer ce qu'ils imaginent ce
matin que j'ai je prends un sac d'os
j'en viens ici
walo ça coule comme un bol comme ça dans
l'espace
là avec si on peut mettre de l'eau comme
ça si on en restait là
collé sur nous lou va rester collés sur
nous et là tu peux te frotter avec un
peu de savon quand tes propres
tu prends une serviette dans les flots
et voilà donc on se lave un peu comme
ont l'air un bébé un morceau à la fois
en l'air un brin lave le bras la jambe
la loggia 929 tondo qu'à la fin c'est
propre c'est comme ça qu'on se lave un
morceau à la fois et maintenant je
laisse la parole à monsieur david lam et
y avait déjà une question pour toi
est-ce que tu est en mesure d'écouter
les matchs du canadien de montréal
ou est-ce que tu dois te contenter avec
la ligue russe oui c'est possible
d'écouter la télévision mais il faut
prévoir davance quelqu'un si quelqu'un
sur terre l'enregistrent et puis il nous
l'envoie puis là on peut écouter mais le
lendemain seulement on peut pas
l'écouter en temps réel comme on se
parle en ce moment fait que j'essaie de
ne pas regarder les résultats comme ça
je peux le voir le lendemain avec la
surprise des vides note david notre
connexion en direct tire déjà à sa fin
je veux te remercier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
c'est une expérience que plusieurs vont
se rappeler toute leur vie nous n'avons
pas tous la chance d'aller dans l'espace
mais grâce aux photos et aux vidéos que
tu nous partageons pendant sa mission
les canadiens pourront suivre ton
aventure merci beaucoup
merci à tout le temps à battre tout le
monde
station